federal judge has just ruled that age
limits on porn on online porn or
unconstitutional so some of us
conservatives have said just ban porn
it's not good it's really bad it leads
to the exploitation of women it leads to
addiction especially for young men it's
in no way good for anybody it's just
it's like it's like any drug we should
just discourage it and ban it ideally
but the the softer more conciliatory
Middle Ground approach is well hey let's
at least make sure that little kids
aren't looking important we know that
the the median age of exposure to porn
these days is something like 10 or 11
years old maybe younger now so let's
just you got to prove that you're at
least 18. just like you used to go buy a
Playboy down the street at the at the
magazine stand you had to show an ID to
do that well let's do that with far more
egregious online pornography and a
federal judge said no no that's
unconstitutional that's a violation of
the First Amendment pornography is not
protected speech